quel sacrifice commence dans le grand
temple du soleil on pachacamac puissante
astres du jour pas chien camac mais oui
à l'époque on avait découvert une statue
de la divinité pachacamac sur un site de
fouilles près de lima à côté du temple
du soleil et hergé a même imaginé des
couleurs alors que les archéologues
viennent tout juste de montrer que les
représentations des divinités été
peintes et multicolore bonjour ou
curieuses et curieux
une équipe d'archéologues français et
péruviens s'est intéressé à cette pièce
conservée au musée archéologique de
pachacamac sma en bois gravé de deux
mètres 34 et une représentation de la
divinité pachacamac considéré par les
incas comme un dieu créateur mais aussi
comme le maître des tremblements terre
pachacamac était également un oracle
puissants que les emprunts cas venez
consulter dans le sanctuaire du même nom
située sur la côte péruvienne au moins
de lima la statue a été découverte en
1938 alors qu'on la croyait détruite par
les espagnols depuis 1533 lors de leur
conquête de l'empiré inca hip hop et
qu'il se trouve qu'elle comportait en
certains endroits des colorations rouge
mystérieuse est-ce que c'était du sang
les restes de pratiques sacrifices elle
en 2019
alors que l'origine de ces taches rouges
étaient toujours pas élucidées des
chercheurs français présents sur le site
de fouilles avaient dans leurs valises
deux micro scope portables utilisant la
fluorescence des rayons x pour analyser
les pierres du temple pas pour
l'anecdote l'un de ces instruments a été
conçu pour aller sur mars ce qui est
quand même vachement la farce c'est
microscope permettent de faire des
analyses chimiques non invasive et non
destructive petit mais costaud les
microscopes sont alors utilisées pour
analyser lidl en bois et il révèle que
le rouge n'est pas la seule couleur
présente on trouve aussi du jeune par
endroits et du blanc sur les dents d'un
personnage les scientifiques détermine
également les éléments chimiques
composant les tâches et ils découvrent
que le rouge n'est pas du sang mais un
pigment qui contient du mercure et du
soufre c'est à dire du cil
un minerai de mercure ont utilisé depuis
plus de 2000 ans dans la région même
s'il existe différents gisements de
cinabre en amérique du sud
ils sont très localisés et chacun
possède une signature chimique qui lui
est propre mais les premiers travaux des
archéologues américains montrent que le
cinabre utilisés dans les andes
avant l'arrivée des espagnols provient
presque exclusivement de la mine de
huancavelica qui est située à près de
400 km de pachacamac ce minerai rouge et
est donc rare et précieux et lidl a
probablement est dépeinte avec
l'intention de montrer un pouvoir
économique et politique
on va tout va peindre cheveux leur en
mettre plein la vue
je veux du blues je vous dis bouge pas
je veux du juge pas tous les mecs disent
tu aimes tu regrettes guen mais ce n'est
pas fini
lidl a également été datés au carbone 14
pour la première fois et il se trouve
qu'elle a été façonnée près de sept
cents ans avant l'apogée de l'empiré
inca aux alentours de 731 après
jésus-christ et probablement par la
civilisation huari ainsi grâce aux
nouvelles technologies les archéologues
ont pu confirmer que les incas avait
bien repris une divinité existant dans
la culture huari bien avant leur arrivée
et que les couleurs étaient utilisés
pour peindre richement les idoles dans
des cultes antérieure aux incas certains
d'entre eux préserver dans le temps même
si la symbolique de ces couleurs restent
encore à découvrir la polychromie change
notre vision des idoles et des monuments
et elle montre l'importance de la
couleur et du choix des matériaux
utilisés dans les rituels en daim avant
l'arrivée des espagnols
voilà je sais que vous attendez un
calembour pour terminer cet épisode mais
ne partez pas nous avons une grande
annonce
au grand est kama
marie line dole à parler tu reprendra le
flambeau de
de science marine
[Musique]
voilà j'ai passé trois belles années
presque trois ans à vos côtés et donc je
voulais vous dire merci merci pour tout
et même si je pars sur de nouvelles
aventures rester sur la station si vous
n'allez pas vous ennuyer et vous êtes en
bonne compagnie marie est bien bonjour à
tous je suis mari et c'est moi qui
reprend le flambeau de là vous verrez on
va passer de bons moments ensemble au
travers de nouvelles aventures rempli de
sciences et d'humour et surtout
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner